bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo l'émission lcp public sénat qui
refait le tour de l'actualité politique
et parlementaire bonjour michaëlle jean
chrétien et cette semaine françois
hollande a renoncé à la mesure qu'il a
prôné le lendemain des attentats du 13
novembre il n'y aura pas de déchéance de
nationalité pour les terroristes
présumés terroristes le chef de l'état a
pris acte de l'échec du parlement a
adopté un texte le commun pas de
révision constitutionnelle la mini du
travail a défendu son texte devant les
députés
c'était en commission le texte qui
réforme le code du travail est très
contesté une nouvelle manifestation a
réuni des centaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues
et puis après les députés les sénateurs
ont examiné le projet de loi qui prévoit
de nouvelles mesures antiterroristes et
réforme la procédure pénale
feu vert pour la perpétuité
incompressible pour les auteurs de
crimes terroristes
notre invité cette semaine pour
commenter toute cette actualité bojan
hervé mariton
bonjour vous êtes député les
républicains de la drôme candidat pour
la primaire de votre parti les
républicains et auteur de ce livre
le printemps des libertés les réformes
qui sauveront la france on va en parler
avec jim jaras est notre partenaire du
figaro ça sera en fin d'émission et
katia a commencé par une polémique oui
polémique lancée par le ministre des
sports patrick kanner c'est lundi
le ministre qui a évoqué la présence en
france d'une centaine de molenbeek le
premier ministre qui a donc lancé la
polémique jordan clyde c'est une phrase
lancée ce week end qui a créé la
polémique il y a aujourd'hui on le sait
une centaine de quartiers en france qui
présente des similitudes potentiel avec
ce qui s'est passé à molenbeek
pour le ministre molenbeek c'est aussi
une concentration de pauvreté de chômage
et de dérive ultra communautariste des
aspects que l'on retrouverait dans
certaines villes françaises entre
stigmatisation et lucidité
les élus de droite applaudissent une
prise de conscience de la part du
gouvernement un peu le langage de vérité
ne nuit pas donc un gain qui dit il ya
des quartiers difficiles sensible où on
a laissé s'installer le communautarisme
et faut être franc gouvernement de
gauche ou de droite mais ce cas nerfs
devrait aller au bout du raisonnement
le cabinet du ministre a tenu à
justifier ces chiffres selon lui il
s'agit de quartier cumulant les
handicaps sociaux figurant sur la liste
des zones prioritaires
à gauche les politiques sont plus
mesurés et pointe du doigt des amalgames
ces quartiers il faut continuer à leur
proposer un nouvel avenir
mais ils ne font pas non plus
stigmatiser dire voilà c'est un quartier
difficile donc ce timide donc
stigmatisation donc radicalisation donc
terrorisme parce que dans ce cas là on
va mettre en cause des millions de
personnes qui n'y sont pour rien
aujourd'hui devant les députés
socialistes manuel valls a approuvé les
propos de son ministre
même si le chef du gouvernement a jugé
difficile les comparaisons
hervé mariton à ce que vous diriez vous
aussi comme patrick kanner qu'il ya des
molenbeek en france et combien
oui oui parce que c'est l'analyse que
les politiques lucine faisant oui parce
que quand j'écoute des experts comme
gilles kepel qui trouve que pour
l'essentiel le propos de patrice
caennais est juste et oui il y a des
quartiers qui ne sont pas sous un
contrôle suffisant en termes de sécurité
des quartiers dans lequel parfois les
municipalités elle-même encourage le
communautarisme des quartiers qui du
fait du
politique de l'urbanisme de l'habitat
mal calibré se sont transformés en
ghettos dans les propositions de mon
livre je propose de changer le concept
de logement social de l'abandonner tel
qu'il a été construit en france parce
qu'ils amènent des municipalités à
construire parfois 50 pour cent soixante
pour cent quatre-vingts penser qu'au
problème est là en sociaux le problème
n'est pas uniquement là mais ça y
contribue
s'il y avait davantage de variétés s'il
y avait davantage un libre choix du
logement pour les personnes modestes
aide à la personne plutôt qu'eads à la
pierre s'il y avait des communes qui de
ce fait est une meilleure diversité mais
pas au sens du politiquement correct
telle qu'on la leur aux naïfs comme l'a
dit michel sapin oui oui c'est exact à
propos de la belgique mais ce qu'on
pourrait nommer clientéliste à la fois
le modèle leaf est aimable en réalité
parce que dans certains cas l'état a
reculé en conscience donc la mauvaise
conscience mais évidemment laxisme des
municipalités qui au fond ont délégué le
contrôle et la paix sociale deus année à
tous et praticiens en frais allégret
donc on s'est beaucoup flatté pendant
quelques années alors que les grands
frères en réalité c'est une espèce
d'intermédiaires pas bien clair pas bien
heureux entre la délinquance et la loi
de la république qui a laissé faire
droite gauche peu importe à la limite
non pas peu importe mais la droite et la
gauche dans une mauvaise compréhension
de la politique de la ville l'idée qu'il
y ait une politique de la ville comme
l'évoquent de cette manière jean pierre
sueur qu'on doive être attentif à des
efforts à la promotion à la solution de
difficultés de certains quartiers
évidemment oui notre reste donc la
politique de la ville telle qu'elle a
été menée jusqu'à présent suffit de
regarder les résultats
ouais donc le fait qu'il y ait une
politique de la ville est quelque chose
de tout à fait bienvenu nécessaire mais
il faut de france mais il faut le faire
avec moins de naïveté
il faut le faire sans considérer que la
seule que le seul versement d'une manne
règlerait le problème
on voit bien que le financement
d'associations qui parfois ont éloigné
de la solution plus qu'elles n'en ont
rapproché n'était pas heureux et que la
politique de
concentration urbaine logements sociaux
sur l'agent sociaux est aussi un échec
mois passés au mardi je voulais bien
mariton avec la ministre du travail qui
était devant les députés
miriam nobre était donc devant la
commission des affaires sociales qui
avait fait le plein c'est vrai ce mardi
le grand oral donc pour myriam el khomri
regarde ce reportage
une ministre enthousiaste qui se targue
de défendre une loi équilibré avec un
objectif principal
réformer profondément notre droit du
travail en donnant beaucoup plus de
place à la négociation collective
mais le rapporteur n'est pas du même
avis le projet de loi pour lui nécessite
encore des précisions notamment pour
rassurer les salariés
s'il est vrai que le contexte au new
economic demande aux entreprises de
pouvoir s'adapter
le contexte économique doit aussi
prendre en compte le fait que les
salariés sont inquiets pour leur avenir
dans l'opposition un mot d'ordre revenir
au texte initial
mais la droite salue quelques
dispositions avec une certaine ironie
saluons les circonvolutions ac auquel
vous vous êtes vous prêter pour remettre
en cause des 35 heures sans le dire
et entre la possibilité de négocier des
taux de majoration des heures
supplémentaires autour de 10% des
accords offensif les communistes
dénoncent le la philosophie même du
texte
la vocation initiale du code du travail
est la protection des salariés ce n'est
pas une modernisation qu'il s'agit mais
d'un retour en arrière pour ne pas dire
très en arrière
l'examen du texte commencera le 4 avril
en commission avant le coup d'envoi dans
l'hémicycle le 3 mai prochain
alors on va rester sur le fond on
abordera les questions socio de
notamment des manifestations un petit
peu plus tard j'imagine que le libéral
que vous êtes et on au programme
beaucoup de choses dans votre livre on
va dire que cette loi ne va pas assez
loin
oui je dis que c'est pas assez loin une
fois qu'on a dit ça oui jusqu'où ou
est-ce qu'on pourrait aller c'est par
exemple sur les tpe les pme sial petites
entreprises les moyennes entreprises il
paraît que le gouvernement pourrait
bouger ce que ça pourrait vous
satisfaire et moi ce que je souhaiterais
c'est qu' il y ait la plus grande
liberté possible dans l'entreprise c'est
ça mon approche de liberté par
que je crois que beaucoup de choses
peuvent se régler dans l'entreprise et
ma vision c'est le principe de
subsidiarité qui m'inspire beaucoup
si on peut trouver une solution dans
l'entreprise on la trouve dans
l'entreprise si on peut la trouver dans
la branche l'autre dans la branche
et si ça n'est pas possible alors il ya
eu droit du travail qui est là pour
résoudre les situations mais cette idée
qui est l'idée sur laquelle est que
voulez vous en effet vous laisser
flotter le code du travail
bon je vais mal et que salariés vont
accepter cela mais si les salariés
acceptent alors c'est que chacun y
trouve son compte
l'employeur les salariés et ça définit
une manière de faire dans l'entreprise
je vais pas disparaître toute règle il
ya ce qu'on appelle l'ordre social
public assez largement définie par des
textes européens aujourd'hui et je ne
propose pas de faire sauter l'ordre
social public mais je dis que le code du
travail tel qu'il existe depuis des
décennies en france qui est dans l'idée
totalement de protéger le faible
salariés supposément opprimés par
l'entreprise
ça ne fonctionne pas cette manière là
aujourd'hui et chaque fois qu'un accord
peut être trouvé alors cet accord doit
prévaloir sans qu'il y ait une
contrainte supplémentaire d'un code du
travail
et là où il n'y a pas accord il y a un
col subsidiaire supplétifs qui permet de
réserver situation vous avez vous avez
un modèle ailleurs en europe parce que
ce serait suivre la voie qu'a suivi par
exemple matteo renzi en italie ou plutôt
un modèle à l'allemande ou alors un
autre modèle c'est une vision
franchement neuf qui est celle de
l'accord local qui on y fait est plus
proche de ce qui existe dans d'autres
pays qui n'ont pas les mêmes contraintes
que le code du travail très rigide à la
française mais c'est inventer quelque
chose de neuf parce que nous sommes
indépendants nouvelle comparé vraiment
de de la base de du constat d'un
consentement
parfois ça prend du temps donc à ce
moment là il ya un code du travail qui
continue de s'appliquer tant qu'on n'a
pas trouvé une solution
localement si on la trouve c'est
l'accord local qui définit sous réserve
de leur social public
si on ne la trouve pas alors il ya de
nouveau un code du travail supplétifs
mais qui voyait bien que le monde du
travail changent la pratique du travail
le goût du travail
les gens ne sont pas nécessairement à
leur boulot 20 35 heures sur 35 ou 40
heures sur 40
et puis le temps de travail la réalité
c'est qu'on continue de tourner autour
de ce débat les 35 heures la loi comme
ris et les dérogations autour d'une
règle pour idée transition de cinq
heures oui parce que un le temps de
travail en france globalement est
insuffisant mais deux les réponses sont
très variables
il ya des boîtes où on peut trouver une
réponse
32 heures ou à 30 heures accueil tant
mieux il ya des entreprises où on peut
trouver une réponse à 42 heures étant je
dois préparer votre part je voterai pas
parce qu'ils étaient insuffisantes et le
départ de mon point de vue est qu'il est
encore plus lacunaire aujourd'hui
j'ajoute que la réponse que je propose
je pensais et la bonne réponse parce que
elle elle ne sont pas dans une vision
une vision qui donne un espoir aux gens
une autre forme de relation au travail
et si vous n'êtes pas dans la vision si
vous êtes dans la mesure purement
paramétrer kippel conneries alors vous
avez des manifs
alors on reparlera de votre vision tout
à l'heure d'abord je vous propose à
mardi de voir l'actualité de votre party
les républicains qui a tenu son bureau
politique à l'ordre du jour le
changement de certaines règles pour les
primaires seuls les parlementaires de
droite pourront parrainer les candidats
écoutez la réaction de nathalie
kosciusko morizet à la sortie du bureau
ces modifications qui est proposée par
des acteurs qui sont eux mêmes impliqués
dans la primaire candidats aux futurs
candidats et c'est un mauvais présage
que de s'organiser ainsi pour changer
les règles du jeu à son profit
est ce que je retiens c'est qu'on
cherche par des mesures administratives
à écarter ma candidature je trouve pas
qu'il soit légitime de chercher dans une
primaire ouverte à écarter une
candidature par des mesures
administratives alors vous étiez présent
lors de ce bureau politique vous avez
vous été pourquoi vous je suis abstenu
je suis revenu parce que sur le fond
demandé que les parlementaires qui
paraît une créature adhèrent aux valeurs
de la droite et du centre les
parlementaires sens dans les centres et
savent parrainer parlementaires
centristes peuvent parrainer si on nous
explique demain que les parlementaires
centristes peuvent pas parrainer à ce
mois là ça fait exploser le système est
un moment si on se fout de la règle des
primaires à un moment il finira par y
avoir des candidats en dehors des
primaires il faut tout de même que aux
républicains on est certains oui oui
parce que batterie soit la règle est
respectée et je vais revenir là dessus
dans son esprit et dans sa forme et des
statuts ça se respecte
quand il ya quelques moi j'entends un de
mes collègues au bureau politique de
l'ump
à l'époque encore expliqué les statuts
on s'en fout on est là pour faire la
politique
quand mardi soir nicolas sarkozy me
répond mais hervé on n'est pas là pour
faire du juridisme jeudi faut faire
gaffe
il ya un niveau d'adaptation qui est
convenable je me suis abstenu je veux
dire
quoi mais il ya un niveau au delà duquel
l'irrespect de la règle comment serait
opposé de ce que faisait la gueule
visible crédibilité politique c'est pas
que ça m'agace c'est tout c'est un vrai
sujet c'est quelque chose que vous
semblez arriver mais la primaire n'a de
sens que pour autant que la règle soit
solide et said marie c est ce que vous
avez la peau du dos et le crâne n'est
pas solide est pas respectée je vous
réponds s'agissant du vote de mardi soir
prié de dire mais proposait pas voté
contre je me suis abstenu parce que sur
le fond l'idée de demander aux parrains
d'accomplir la même formalité des
électeurs de dire qu'ils adhèrent aux
valeurs de la droite et du centre
ça me paraît cohérent et pourquoi j'ai
pas voté pour parce que un changement
même cohérent de la règle est quelque
chose qui demande une infinie prudence
et je ne veux pas qu'on en rajoute trop
demain voilà c'est extrêmement clair je
vous donne un exemple de terrain lors
d'une mise en garde que vous faites oui
oui la réponse est oui
quand nous avons fixé une règle qui est
que les animateurs locaux les présidents
locaux des comités d'admission des
primaires ne doivent pas être en même
temps secrétaires départementaux des
républicains il a fallu que je démontre
que dans un département cette règle
n'était pas respectée pour qu'on s'en
inquiète et qu'on demande effectivement
aux secrétaires départementaux alors de
renoncer à leurs fonctions
en tout cas de choisir donc voila moi je
suis dans l'exercice dont je passe pas
mon temps à protester de la règle je
demande simplement simplement simplement
sur le respect de la règle qui visez
vous exactement
qui aurait intérêt aujourd'hui à changer
les règles mais je vise large
ça va me faire des ennemis parce que
notre conversion politique a un sens
assez relatif de la règle la phrase que
je vous ai relaté qui est les statuts
qui pas une phrase d'aujourd'hui c'était
il ya quelques mois s'est dit encore le
mp les statuts on s'en fout on est là
pour faire de la politique est une
phrase en réalité qu'on entend souvent
et on voit bien quand en bureau
politique on argumente sur la règle sur
les statuts bien sombre de gens qui
disent hervé était gentil mais si on
pouvait qu'amener la réunion plus vite
ça serait mieux vous vous dites ça
suffit je dis qu'il faut un respect
convenable de la règle alors passé
mercredi françois c'est à nous de la
garde et la règle je rappelle la mère
supérieure douaniers avec des carmélites
ces milliards dont la règle
avec pour l'instant le vans si je peux
me permettre c'est au tour du pin c'est
important parce que pour la présidence
de l'ump j'ai été candidat en novembre
2014 anne levade responsable président
de la haute autorité a parfaitement su
faire valoir règle je souhaite pour la
primaire qu'il soit très clair que
l'autorité c'est anne levade ce n'est
pas thierry et on va parler de la règle
suprême maintenant et françois hollande
qui a annoncé la fin de la révision
constitutionnelle
voilà plusieurs mois de débats plusieurs
polémiques et puis des fractures dans
chaque camp à droite comme à gauche est
plus présent de la république qui a pris
ses responsabilités qui a dit que rapid
e révision constitutionnelle on voit
tout cela qu'elle a monaghan à 5 minutes
d'allocution qui signe la fin de quatre
mois de débat autour de la révision
constitutionnelle
je constate aujourd'hui quatre mois
après que l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat ne sont pas parvenus à se mettre
d'accord sur un même texte et qu'un
compromis par mm hors d'atteinte sur la
définition de la déchéance de
nationalité pour les terroristes
aussi j'ai décidé après m'être entretenu
avec les présidents de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat de clore le débat
constitutionnel pour être présenté à
versailles il fallait que la réforme
soit adoptée dans les mêmes termes par
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
les socialistes rejettent en bloc la
faute sur l'opposition et notamment la
droite sénatoriale
nous n'avons pas convaincu la droite en
général et la droite sénatoriale en
particulier de rentrer dans l'union
nationale pour renforcer notre droit
dans la lutte contre le terrain mais
l'opposition n'entend pas être tenu pour
responsable de cet échec
elle le rappelle la version votée par le
sénat c'est presque la même que la
version initiale du gouvernement
présenté en décembre dernier
républicains étaient décidés à voter
la déchéance de nationalité pour les
binationaux
monsieur hollande nous avait proposé la
déchéance pour les binationaux
puis est arrivé l'histoire du retrait de
la nationalité pour les nationaux mais m
messieurs ça n'a aucun sens
quatre mois de déchirures qui laisseront
des traces surtout dans la majorité
cette annonce est il un échec personnel
pour françois hollande ou y at il une
responsabilité collective
c'est un échec pour françois hollande
simplement je suis de ceux qui parmi les
premiers ont eu le courage de dire parce
que c'est une position assez minoritaire
à l'époque oui que ces déchéances de
nationalité était une proposition qui
n'avait aucun sens s'il fallait pas
toucher à la con parce que mais surtout
que la déchéance de nationalité serait
une mesure inopérante inefficace qui
n'est pas une manière intelligente de
réponde aux terroristes qui s'en fichent
qui voire même pouvait être flatté d'une
réponse politique de cette nature au
terrorisme on répond par d'une mise en
cause du criminel qu'elle terroriste la
réponse aux terroristes aller sur le
terrain criminel on criminalise le
terroriste et on ne lui donne pas un
statut politique
un regret de ne pas avoir révisé la
constitution au moins peut-être sur
l'état d'urgence par l'état d'urgence on
voit bien que l'état d'urgence et mis en
oeuvre aujourd'hui dans des conditions
utile sans qu'il y eu besoin de réviser
la constitution
donc là ils ont la conscience pour
l'état d'urgence n'est pas utile la
déchéance de nationalité est une très
mauvaise mesure
c'est en plus l'exemple même du symbole
pour rien et et nicolas sarkozy qui a
beaucoup soutenu cette mesure en disant
il faut des symboles a eu tort aussi
parce que un symbole qui n'embraye sur
aucune réalité concrète
un symbole qui n'en breil sur aucun
progrès tangibles dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme et c'est le cas de cette
mesure qu'elle a comme les chances de
nationalité alors le symbole à un moment
s'est fondé sur l'humain donc cédé 7,2
contre hollande et nicolas sarkozy on
vous entend bien oui parce que cette
mesure a été porté par ceux qui ont
voulu faire de la com com françois
hollande sur un sujet aussi
considérables dommages
ceux qui n'ont pas osé dit
la vérité ce qu'ils ont considéré que
dès lors qu'ils avaient un mot viril
vigoureux fort en apparence il fallait
embrayé parce que faut suivre le
mouvement
et ben non la politique de temps en
temps ça suppose de l'honnêteté ça
suppose de la lucidité ça suppose du
courage et de la pédagogie
françois hollande a été dans la com
nicolas sarkozy avait embrayé à ce
moment là je suis fait partie des
quelques uns nous le courage de dire la
vérité dès le début alors trois heures
après cette annonce manuel valls a
fustigé 8 devant la représentation
nationale
la main tant la latitude pardon de la
droite sénatoriale a écouté la droite
sénatoriale s'oppose à une mesure que
les français ont parfaitement compris
l'extension mais c'est en fait on est
côte la réponse de la nationalité pour
les terroristes qui prennent les armes
pour tuer leurs propres compatriotes
une mesure une mesure voulue par
l'opposition une mesure que le président
la république et l'exécutif dépassant
les frontières partisanes a voulu mettre
en oeuvre dans un souci d'unité mesure
et vous le savez bien qui a coûté à la
gauche
la menace terroriste reste très élevé
sur notre territoire
mais l'union nationale du coup nous
n'existe plus si la menace terroriste
on répond par des mesures pratiques qui
sont celles d'un meilleur équipement
d'un meilleur armement de nos services y
compris en terme de personnels
compétents des linguistes en nombre
suffisant des gens qui savent faire la
différence entre l'arabe de mauritanie
l'arabe d'irak
tout ce dont malheureusement nos
services sont largement privé
aujourd'hui aux terroristes on répond en
les prenant pour ce qu'ils sont c'est à
dire des criminels qui mérite la réponse
que doivent avoir les îles à cause d'un
vol habité barbare mais je suis cohérent
la déchéance de nationalité c'est vrai
manuel valls a raison de dire que ça
avait été proposée par la droite en son
temps mais j'avais déjà à l'époque
exprimé que je n'étais pas d'accord avec
ces propositions et puis dans la
philosophie de la faire le sujet de la
france aujourd'hui y compris pour
affirmer notre identité notre force la
résilience des français dans l'ue de
contrôler terre
c'est dire ce qu'est être français et
non pas ce qui est en sortir je suis
pour le droit du sang parce c'est ça la
bonne réponse c'est dire ce qu'est être
français
l'enjeu de notre pays c'est de dire
comment on est français que 10 et non
pas vous prive dans l'être françois
fillon a eu cette remarque ce vendredi
la cité l'exemple de manuel valls qui
qualifie de manoeuvrier sans envergure
vous irait jusque là aussi nous c'est
pas le sujet enfin je crois que c'est
pas le sujet valeureux tout cela oui
mais non mais je ne dis pas ça voyez
vous pas ce que je pense que c'est la
mesure elle même qui s'effondre dire qu
un symbole qui embraye sur une réalité
alors ça vaut la peine je ne récuse pas
toute idée de symbole mais on m'a dit
mme hervé c'est important c'est un
symbole un symbole pourquoi un symbole
pour rien et bien symbole qui n'ont
braye sûr que l'usure concrètes
à un moment ça c'est faux vous avez là
comme s'effondrer au fond méditons cette
leçon que la politique résumer à de la
communication sans embrayage dans la
réalité des considérations de la droite
qui par manque de courage n'ose pas
expliquer aux français
eh ben l'excès de communication la
suffisance de pédagogie à un moment
faire démarrer tongres et vu que le
premier ministre des prêts aux sénateurs
on va écouter quelques sénateurs
justement qui aurait agi à cela le
président de la république a joué avec
le feu il veut faire porter la
responsabilité sur les autres alors que
c'est sa responsabilité propre son rôle
c'était de réunir avant de s'engager
les différents présidents de chambres du
parlement mais aussi les présidents de
groupe pour caler les choses avant et
pas après en réalité il n'a que ce qu'il
mérite
la priorité de nos concitoyens ce n'est
pas cette révision constitutionnelle ce
sont les problèmes de sécurité ce sont
les problèmes de chômage ce sont les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat et ce texte
c'est la manière dont ils avaient été
lancés démontre que ça ne répondait pas
aux priorités des français qu' il est
sage
aujourd'hui de tourner cette page à
tourner la page jeux politiciens
ça suffit c'est vrai on a perdu beaucoup
de temps avec une mesure inefficace et
inopérant tôt que travaillons
sérieusement dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et travaille au service aux
petits jeux et autres c'est dans
l'assemblée non jérôme s'arrête ça j'en
viens à temps on évoque quand même
toujours là une révision de la
constitution possible sur un autre sujet
celui de la réforme du conseil supérieur
de la magistrature est ce que pour vous
c'est indispensable ou pas donc ce n'est
pas indispensable à ma connaissance sur
la période la plus récente l'exécutif
n'a jamais passé mais j'avais passé
outre l'avis du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature y compris à l'égard des
magistrats du parquet on a autre chose à
faire enfin ya plein de choses qui
marchent pas en france sénateurs mais a
raison de dire dans le domaine de
l'économie de l'emploi du chômage donc
quoi la révision du conseil supérieur de
magistrature par la cour
constitutionnelle au jeu concernant
franchement il n'y a pas de nécessité de
réformes institutionnelles en france
aujourd'hui
ni aujourd'hui ni demain d'accord on va
passer à un autre sujet pendant ce temps
là le sénat examine élus le projet de
loi sur la réforme pénale ils ont adopté
le principe d'une perpétuité
incompressible ça veut dire une mesure
qui permettrait de porter la période de
sûreté jusque pour les terroristes
jusqu'à 30 ans de prison
tous les détails des explications avec
faustine sa jeunesse un texte plus
musclée et plus sévères s'il emprunte
apportées au projet de loi urvoas par le
sénat à majorité de droite et du centre
objectif donner davantage de moyens
d'enquêté d'action contre le terrorisme
parmi les mesures emblématiques voulue
par les républicains la fameuse
perpétuité réelle qui est en fait un
allongement de la période de sûreté dans
le respect de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme et de la
constitution nous sommes allés au plus
loin qu'il est possible d'aller la
période de sûreté a été portée de 22 ans
à 30 ans autre modification controversée
la création de deux nouveaux délits
le délit de consultation de sites
terroristes puni de deux ans de prison
et 30 mille euros d'amande et le délit
de séjour sur un théâtre d'opérations
terroristes certains socialistes
regrettent qu'une surenchère sécuritaire
là je pense qu'on n'est pas du tout dans
un pragmatisme on est dans un affichage
comment est ce que la justice arrivera à
assimiler et à utiliser
tous les délits toutes les infractions
nouvelle que vous essayez de mettre en
oeuvre un texte crucial pour le
gouvernement alors que l'état d'urgence
arrive à échéance le 26 mai prochain
est ce que ce texte correspond à vos
attentes oui je crois qu'il ya des
mesures qui sont justifiés et qui sont
nécessaires dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et les sénateurs de droite
ont eu raison
je vais observer par exemple sur les
mots vains soyons précis il s'agit pas
de perpétuité réelle
il s'agit d'une augmentation de la
période de sûreté et de faire en sorte
qu'une décision de justice soit
nécessaire et qu'il n'y ait pas de
libération automatique un moment donné
mais donc que la perpétuité soit
encadrée de cette manière là je trouve
que les sénateurs voit juste points 13
honnête à l'égard des français a raison
d'appeler sa perpétuité réelle parce que
ça ne l'est pas non mais reconnaissez
que c'est un peu curieux c'est confond
tout pour sa part de ça a été annoncé
comme mauvais oui mais c'est sa voix qui
nous va très bien je je je suis un
esprit un peu rigoureux qu'est-ce qu'ils
iraient à la place qu est-ce que vous
soumettez je trouve que ce qui a été
voté par le sénat va bien savourer je
dis simplement une remarque est temps de
vendre français de la fausse monnaie
parce que les français avant ils s'en
rendent compte et isin c'est quoi ces
gens c'est pas sérieux nous allongeons
la période de sûreté nous rendons plus
difficile l'élargissement la personne
nous en sorte qu'il n'y ait rien
d'automatique avec une décision de
justice qui sera très difficile à
obtenir pour le condamner mais pas
totalement impossible donc faut juste et
honnête dans les matelas aurait elle
enfin voilà quoi
alors ce texte instaure des mesures
censées servir quand l'état d'urgence
aura cessé en france
est ce que pour vous elles sont
parfaitement suffisante pour permettre
aux forces de l'ordre de réagir à temps
pour arrêter par exemple quelqu'un comme
reda cricket c'est suffisant il ne
manque rien mais tu aurais je viens je
serai bien imprudent a vous dit il le
manque rien
ce fonctionnement il faut pas qu'on soit
uniquement dans cette logique de loi
supplémentaire je pense qu'ils aient
besoin de moyens et je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure des exemples extrêmement
technique est aussi une question un
enjeu
je l'expliqué dans mon livre de
mobilisation de l'ensemble la population
il vaut la peine de regarder comment des
pays sous la menaces répétées de
terrorisme contexte différent royaume
uni israël sont des pays qui sont des
démocraties qui vivent ou les gens vont
aux spectacles vont à la plage vont
restos vont en boîte vont au boulot
et en même temps sont très attentifs à
la lutte contre l'intolérance doit ces
affaires de vigilance sur ce qui se
passe dans certains quartiers c'est à
faire le suivi de personnes s'est
affirmée mission du citoyen juste un
exemple je n'ai pas voté la loi
renseignement il ya quelques mois
pourquoi parce que la logique de l'avoir
enseignement c est temps de le filer
plus en plus large
or on voit bien avec les terroristes qui
ont été mis en cause ces derniers mois
que ce soit à bruxelles à paris sont des
gens qui étaient déjà dans le radar donc
il faut c'est ça l'enjeu qu'on soit
beaucoup plus efficace à suivre des gens
qui soient dans le radar plutôt que
d'être dans une espèce de surenchère
perpétuelle qui consiste à élargir le
radar à étendre le filet plus loin y
compris parfois en mettant en cause un
son de libertés publiques
je suis pas chaud chaud hot et en même
temps je suis attaché aux libertés
publiques
surtout je cherche l'efficacité
l'exemple de la loire enseignement est
intéressant à cet égard est temps de le
radar est temps de le filer sa pas
beaucoup d'intérêt voire même ça fait
beaucoup compliqué les choses
de nouveaux comme la déchéance ça fait
chic on dit aux gens regardez on les
courageux on prend des vraies mesures
puis la réalité derrière elle est un peu
modeste faut se réveiller
il faut surtout y avoir une action juste
bien calibré mobiliser aussi les
citoyens la lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est la sphère de tous les autres
sujets capteurs michel sapin cherche lui
aussi à avoir plus d'efficacité il a
présenté mercredi son nouveau projet de
loi en conseil des ministres nommés
sapin deux missions lutter contre la
corruption dans les entreprises à alex
pichot en matière de transparence et de
lutte contre la corruption la france a
du retard à rattraper sur 104 pays notés
elle se classe seulement à la 23e place
faute absolument rompre le cercle de la
défiance entre les citoyens et les
acteurs publics ou privés tout d'abord
le texte prévoit la création d'une
agence nationale de détection et de
prévention de la corruption
ce n'est pas un machin administratives
de plus mais bien un organisme au large
pouvoir chargé de conseiller de forme et
de contrôler et de sanctionner le cas
échéant en plus de la protection des
lanceurs d'alerté de la création d'un
registre de lobbyistes la future agence
placé sous l'autorité des ministères de
la justice et des finances sera aussi
chargée de surveiller les entreprises de
plus de 500 salariés
et dont le chiffre d'affaires est
supérieur à 100 millions d'euros ces
entreprises devront mettre en oeuvre des
procédures de détection et de prévention
des faits de corruption ou de trafic
d'influencé
l'autre volet du texte concerne lui la
modernisation de la vie des entreprises
les auto entrepreneurs pourront
notamment continuer à bénéficier d'un
régime fiscal simplifié pendant deux ans
et ce même en cas de bons chiffres
d'affaires
en revanche ce qui devait être la
disposition phare la transaction pénale
a été retoqué par le conseil d'état est
ce que pour vous hervé mariton et y
avait besoin d'une loi comme celle ci
est ce que cette agence nationale de
détection et de prévention de la
corruption ne sera pas un comité
théodule devants dans cette voie il ya
quelques occasions manquées le dernier
point qui a été évoqué on pouvait
espérer les up membres de la capacité de
faire des auto entrepreneurs le texte
est en réalité beaucoup plus sympa qui
fait loin pour espérer ça ne va pas
assez loin l'auto-entrepreneur c'était
une bonne idée du précédent mandat
c'est dommage que le gouvernement n'est
pas le courage de faciliter encore des
sur le stream et de la dynamique de
l'entreprise sur le reste lutter contre
la corruption c'est tout à fait bienvenu
l'économie de marché au passage est la
meilleure manière de lutter contre la
corruption
quand vous avez des économie administrée
regardez le scandale petrobras au brésil
avec un pays qui a une économie trop
administrés eh bien vous voyez la
situation dans laquelle se trouve la
présidente brésilienne aujourd'hui car
plus l'économie est administré plus vous
avez de la corruption
regardez aussi en russie donc je dis ça
le libéral que je suis sait ce qu'il dit
et quand j'entends parfois des gens à
gauche ou à droite disent oh il faudrait
plus de régulation oulala l'europe est
une catastrophe
oh là là la concurrence non non vous
demandez-vous de religion ça et bien la
réalité c'est que le plus fière
dirigisme qu'ils soient français ou
européens où vous le mettez le plus haï
de corruption michel sapin a raison
lutter contre la corruption
tout simplement une observation c'est
qu'il faut à la fois lutter contre la
corruption
lutter contre la fraude fiscale faisons
attention que un certain nombre d'
équilibre budgétaire aujourd'hui dans
l'exécution du budget de l'état sont
assurés par les bonnes nouvelles
extérieur type bas taux d'intérêt
prix du pétrole bas mais aussi par un
meilleur rendement de la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale
ça c'est très bien en soi il faut pas
que ça devienne le seul paramètre
d'ajustement du budget parce que sinon
on risque de se trouver avec des
services pour des objectifs quantitatifs
et amant vous pouvez avoir un problème
de relation avec les contributions
et de mépris de l'équipe de la relation
entre les services fiscaux les
contribuables entreprises ou partie du
voile a pour ce sujet on va passer au
jeudi c'était jour de grève et de
manifestations il était un petit peu
plus de plusieurs milliers en tout cas
dans les rues de france a manifesté le
mode horde évidemment c'était la
suppression du projet de loi travail
le gouvernement dit entendre mais en
tout cas ne veut compte pas céder 7 les
explications de jérôme bonnard
cet après midi dans toute la france
selon la cgt et force ouvrière
ils étaient deux fois plus au moins que
le 9 mars dernier
plus rien ne freine la mobilisation ni
la pluie ni les modifications du texte
de la loi travail annoncé lundi 14 mars
par le premier ministre manuel valls
aujourd'hui le ton se durcit et vise
toute la classe politique
je pense que les parlementaires au delà
du gouvernement les parlementaires eux
aussi doivent écouter le mécontentement
est donc ils doivent dire on recommence
à zéro
il doit dire au gouvernement faut
recommencer à zéro ce projet de loi
n'est pas bon et donc il faut
retravailler un vrai code du travail
moderne qui protège les salariés sans
l'obtention de nouveaux droits sociaux
il ne reste pour les centrales
protestataires presque aucune marge de
négociation avec le gouvernement voyant
public a été sage hier il a retiré son
projet sur la déchéance de nationalité
bah faudrait qu'il soit sage aujourd'hui
aussi qu'ils comprennent que il faut
retirer ce projet doit encore mettre
tout sur la table on rediscute on n'a
jamais dit qu'on était pour le status
quo mais il faut rediscuter au fond du
dossier
la cgt a promis en fin de journée
d'amplifier l'action
les grèves les manifestations notamment
le 5 avril en direction des
parlementaires
le samedi 9 avril et après jusqu'au
retrait de ce projet de loi
alors arrêtons je vous présente jaime
jara c'est notre partenaire du scan fait
d'ailleurs ces deux ans aujourd'hui bon
anniversaire jean marie venir dans deux
petites minutes de bord katia sur le
fond sur les manifestations
oui une question nouvelle journée
d'action et de grève il y en aura
d'autres promet la cgt bientôt la rue
aura-t-elle raison de l'arrêt
alcon riz pour vous la rue surtout
l'incohérence du gouvernement fait que
la loi va être vidé des quelques
éléments intéressants qui pouvait y
avoir de dents c'est pas imprévisible
puisque de toute manière les quelques
progrès j'ai dit alors que la loi était
insuffisante j'y reviens de rêver
quelques progrès que y avoir de dents
n'étaient d'évidence pas annoncée dans
le programme de françois hollande en
2012 donc faire les choses trop
différente de ce que vous annoncez au
moment de l'élection ça fonctionne
normalement
la réalité se venge mais moi je trouve
que là la vision que je propose on a
évoqué tout à l'air beaucoup plus
audacieuse la suppression du code du
travail au sens où partout on peut
trouver un accord dans l'entreprise cet
accord doit prévaloir
et bien ça c'est une vision ça ça donne
véritablement un objectif possible
un espoir aussi des des progrès à
espérer au sein de chaque entreprise et
avec une réforme audacieuse comme celle
que je propose à mon avis vous n'avez
pas les manifs que vous avez là quand ya
pas de vision quand vous avez cette
logique de dérogation garde les 35
heures mais on essaye de tourner autour
du truc sur les prud'hommes on veut
encadrer les décisions mais pas trop aux
couleurs jaillissent mais un chiffre pas
contraignant au l'économie en réalité
l'emploi les salariés les entreprises il
ya eu rien mais vous avez tous les
motifs du monde pour manifester avec
bret ont tout le monde demande le
retrait est ce que vous aussi vous
demander aujourd'hui le retrait de ce
texte
non je suis pas dans ce cadre-là d'abord
je ne suis pas présent la république au
champ droit pour le cabba non mais il ya
dans ce texte je le dis en somme de
mesures autres oeuvres est utile
attendez moi je ne ferais pas ça c'est
pour ça si vous levez pas le retrait par
retrait c'est un jeu entre le
gouvernement et sa majorité
c'est pas mon sujet mon sujet c'est de
dire que l'enjeu de l'emploi est
évidemment tout à fait considérable dans
notre pays et que d'autres pays en
europe et dans le monde s'en sorte mieux
et que ça ne peut mieux fonctionné en
france qu'avec une vision beaucoup plus
autonome de la nano ou une femme qui la
porte vous dites il manque à la france
peut-être un matteo renzi mme margaret
thatcher ou ou un hervé mariton mes
goûts des jus tignes en tout cas qu'il
manque surtout à la france mais l'audace
dans la liberté la force des valeurs
c'est votre je suis celui qui porte ce
projet je suis donc l'homme de la
situation à l'est on passe au scanner la
loupe du scan 7 avec tim jarrassé
voilà jean c'est à vous et de 10 servie
mariton geoffroy didier vient de
s'ajouter cette semaine à la longue
liste des candidats à la primaire dans
laquelle vous figurer est ce que cette
multiplication des candidatures ne
démonétise pas un peu le l'engagement
que représente le fait d'être candidat
là la halle à la présidence de la
république à l'elysée oui je suis
candidat à l'élection présidentielle par
les primaires sur la base d'un projet
d'une passion d'un engagement d'un
combat que je mène
d'autres pourraient mener je trouve que
d'autres ne le mène pas sur cette
exigence de liberté et de valeurs qui
serait plus banal probablement dans
d'autres pays qui s'en sortent mieux que
nous mais en france il ya toujours une
certaine hésitation par rapport à la
liberté un pays qui s'est construit avec
beaucoup de dirigisme par rapport aux
valeurs un pays
hélas très complexée par rapport à son
nid d'entités je porte cela parce que
c'est indispensable une ligne dédiée
cinq candidats ou clients neva je serais
d'accord qui dit plus de candidats dit
aussi moins de parrainage disponible
c'est mathématique vous devez en
récolter 20 de la part de deux
parlementaires vous on est tous très
précisément aujourd'hui mais aucun
candidat n'a aucun aujourd'hui monsieur
tout simplement monsieur les formidables
parrainage n'ont pas été en france on
dénombre sont cités par tel ou tel
candidat quand vous discutez a été
parlementaire en question voir et c'est
plus compliqué je vous rappelle que
j'avais eu plus de cinquante
parlementaires
les soutiens au monde la présidence de
l'ump que je suis dans une relation
fluide avec mes collègues je ne les
harcèle pas en même temps le temps
maintenant avance et en effet je suis
dans une démarche et les formulaires
sont disponibles à partir de la fin du
mois d'avril qui consiste à demander aux
uns et aux autres de confirmer leur
position leur bonne engagement à mon
égard dont je suis sera en même temps
c'est un travail auquel je suis aussi
attentif mais je veux juste vous dire je
reviens sur cette affaire du nombre de
candidats à la primaire républicaine aux
états unis au début il y avait plus
d'une vingtaine de candidats
la presse américaine plus courageuses et
plus travailleuse peut-être que la
presse française a été capable
d'organiser des débats
foxnews facebook c'est pas des débutants
avec dix sept candidats en deux
séquences en prime time
le soir les 10 les mieux que de vous
demander mais oui parce que ça serait
bien pour quoi vous laisser enfermer
dans l'idée qu'au fond
ce chiffre est insurmontable moi je
trouve que mes regards et aux états unis
ça fonctionne plutôt bien de même que i
pad journalistes tous les trois vous
êtes très talentueux mais qui nous
disent aujourd'hui tous meilleurs vous
pensez tout ça même chose donc d'abord
il ya pas de raison qu il tente
candidats vous reprenez le mode nicolas
sarkozy qu est dit enfin pas vous mais
certains journalistes
la semaine dernière nicolas sarkozy dit
c'est un cirque du raïs qui lisent
certains s'y est un signe de 100 foot
dit
certains d'entre vous pas vous vous êtes
les meilleurs mais d'autre part
construction vous dites tous la même
chose évidemment ça vous dispense de
lire les bouquins et savoir ce qu'on dit
précisément épaves ou non y en a en tout
cas c'est un signe de bonne santé
oui mais il ya des idées il ya un
candidat qui a pas besoin de parrainage
il s'agit de jean frédéric poisson sont
sa candidature en tant que candidat du
parti chrétien démocrate est donc pas
candidat des républicains a été validé
cette semaine par le bureau politique
est ce que vous trouvez normal qu'ils
bénéficient d'une sorte de passe droit
techniquement c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça parce que la démarche
centrée sur la candidature de jean
frédéric poisson n'a pas été validé en
tant que tel vous savez les débats que
nous avons eus en être le seul candidat
officiel aujourd'hui et c'est pas comme
ça que ça a été présenté par les
républicains donc ça il n'y a pas deux
il ya pas de il le fait pas sur la même
ligne mais pas cherché à faire le jeu
entrée libre
alors je parle de votre bouquin nous on
la lui en tout cas je vous l'assuré
d'ici il s'appelle le printemps des
libertés se fait un plaisir c'était un
grand plaisir il commence par cette
épigraphe de soljenitsyne vous êtes un
russophiles averti personne sur la terre
n'a d'autre issue que d'aller toujours
plus haut prix vous voulez aller
jusqu'au bout hervé mariton le bonheur
de la france le bonheur des français
c'est très haut le bonheur c'est un
objectif très très haut et c'est ça qui
me motive en politique donc et dont je
suis l'objet d'analysés je suis candidat
à l'élection présidentielle parce que je
pense que ceux de l'autre je suis pas né
avec la première que je me suis rasé
comme adolescent je ne suis pas sûr
d'être posé cette question devant la
glace et c'est probablement par rapport
à d'autres et peut-être par rapport à
certains journalistes une tare insoluble
parce que vous n'aimez pas vous j'ai
déjà assez mais en gros la classe
médiatique politique et plus
impressionné par les combattants de
toujours et voire intime qui intervient
dans le débat mais qui a plutôt fait le
boulot jusqu'à présent mais dont un
collègue disait il ya quelques mois
invitant débat vous verrez le débat avec
marine chance à être passionnant il ya
des idées c'est un type super et en plus
il a une grande qualité il n'a pas
d'ambition et ben voila je présente les
choses différemment parce qu'à un moment
il me paraît indispensable de porter ces
idées ce projet qui me paraît utile à
mon pays
justement parlons guide et vous proposer
une série de mesures chocs dans votre
livre suppression de ce système dh et là
nous en parler alors suppression du code
du travail vous en ligne allemand parlé
smic modulable franchement margaret
thatcher à côté de vous c'est une colère
générale ou plomb vraiment là dessus
elle a pris du retard de 20 minutes
je constate simplement qu'ils étaient
pays comme le royaume uni vous le site
et qui aujourd'hui s'en sortent mieux
donc je vais aujourd'hui c'est quoi les
perspectives en france quand c'est la
gauche c'est le déclin rapide quand
c'est la droite c'est le déclin lent
j'ai envie de sortir
transaero logique là et oui je fais des
propositions l'impôt universel et
proportionnelle parce qu'on a besoin
d'un système fiscal plus juste et pas la
fausse réforme qui est celle de la rue
de la source très rapidement pour
terminer nicolas sarkozy a rappelé
encore cette semaine qu'il souhaitait
adopter un programme commun pour le
parti avant la primaire est-ce que vous
l'impression qu'ils essayent de vous
imposer un carcan idéologique excusez
moi monsieur décor nicolas sarkozy
continue d'expliquer que les 35 heures
c'est le nirvana en quelque sorte et que
seul sujet c'est les exos de charges par
rapport aux 35 heures quand nicolas
sarkozy dit qu'il faut baisser les
impôts plus vite que les dépenses encore
nicolas sarkozy continue de dire qu'il
faut spécialisé l'économie française au
niveau du smic en mettant tout l'effort
public sur des baisses de charges au
niveau du smic ça ça s'appelle
l'enfermement de l'économie française
dans une vision tiers monde disait eh
bien cette vision économique je suis
radicalement en désaccord avec c'est dit
c'est dit et c'est terminé merci
beaucoup d'humour assez merci hervé
mariton se retrouve donc la semaine
prochaine 4 à la semaine prochaine très
bonne ces deux programmes sur lcp public
sénat merci